hi there today we'll look at rethinking
the truly unsupervised image to image
translation
by kyung junai baik yoon jae choi
yong jung oo ja jung yu
and hyun jung
so in this paper we'll deal with image
to image
translation in an unsupervised fashion
so on a high level they replace the need
for
domain or really single image label
annotations in image to image
translation
by training a guiding network that is
able to
sort of do a self clustering of the
image domain
and therefore that guides the image to
image translation
instead of the previously needed labels
i myself don't know too much about image
to image translation and style transfer
and all of this stuff
this has always been kind of a mystery
to me
and will try to make as much sense as
possible
out of this paper if you're with me i
might not get everything
right but i um will give my best of
course
as always if you like content like this
consider sharing it out and
leaving a like and a comment i do read
the comments
so i get a good idea of what you have to
say about it
cool so what we're seeing here is an
example of
image to image translation of like a
sort of a style transfer
now what you'll have on the left is a
source image
now the goal is to translate this source
image
to a different domain while sort of
keeping the
the features of the image the same and
here is sort of
i'm always confused because here it's
like we keep the pose
of the cat the same okay so we sort of
keep the same cut
but we want to change its uh its style
which means its breed
in this particular case so on the top
you can see
that the domain images are
they come in these different groups and
in fact it's not only those four
but the entire data set is split into
these different groups
and among these different groups you
have some sort of
a shared style now this shared style
is what you would like to transfer to
the source
image so if you transfer the style of
all of these cats
right here which all seem to be sort of
ginger cats
to this instance right here what you'll
end up with
is a cat okay it was ginger before might
not be the best
example but you you sort of get uh what
i mean
is that the thing that you transfer is
whatever is common
among these domain images okay
and that's what i guess explains why the
pose of the cat
stays the same because it only
it is basically taught to keep the image
the same
except to transfer whatever is common
among
the images in the domain class
and that's image to image transfer or
translation
now until this paper at least that's
what the paper claims
these image to image translation models
they required
labels and why is that that's because
um you need to know how
to build these domains here at the top
to get these
different style vectors out or you
actually would need
label annotations for each image for
each single image
you would need to know which one you
need to know which one of the source
corresponds to which one of the target
so they have a graphic right here
where they explain the sort of different
uh
the different stages that image to image
translation went through historically
so first you'd have to have
corresponding images one to one
where you'd say okay here is an example
of a sketch of a shoe
and here is the corresponding shoe here
is the sketch of another and here is the
corresponding shoe and so on
and from that you could learn a model
that translates
from one domain to the other because you
have
corresponding image level annotations
which image corresponds to which so
basically which element of the domain a
corresponds to which element in the
domain b
then the next stage of this was when you
only need
set level annotations and that's sort of
what we looked at
if you had supervised labels for domains
so
what you'll say is that there are three
domains
a b and c and
actually let's let's forget c for a
moment and just deal with a and b
uh to make it equivalent to the thing on
the left now i just know that these
things
are instances of class a and these
things are instances of class b
yet i i don't there's no correspondence
right there is no this corresponds to
this
or or something like this so
image to image translation is now
possible between domains when i just
have
domain level uh labels
but this is still expensive collecting
these labels you know is
is like collecting labels for a
supervised data set
a human needs to look at each image and
then conclude what
sort of domain it is
their paper introduces the following
where you do not have
domains anymore you simply have a data
set
x now this data set your hypothesis
is that there are still going to be
domains in the data set
they can i guess they can be overlapping
or not but there are still going to be
domains you just don't know
what they are so in this case um
i guess you could differentiate these
people into many many
different ways but um in essence you're
going to assume that there is some kind
of a domain structure you just don't
know
what it is but if you knew what it was
then you could just simply apply
methods from here to the data set
and you'd be done now their paper shows
that
if you apply something like a
self-clustering approach and we've seen
these approaches before in
the paper about learning to classify
images without labels
if you have techniques like this you can
do like a self
clustering approach on this data set x
right here
and then you could learn your image to
image translation yet this paper shows
that
if you do that the quality is not as
good
as if you do both things jointly so
what this paper does is it jointly
learns
to cluster let's say to self-label the
images
and to make the to do this image to
image translation
and by doing the tasks jointly they help
each other
perform better okay that's a general
overview
so how do they do this they have three
different
parts to their model there is the
encoder or they call this the guiding
network
there is the generator and there is the
discriminator
so the generator and the discriminator
they are fairly
standard gan generators and
discriminators so general adversarial
network but they have like a bit of some
sort of twists
so you can already see from the
from the drawings right here the
discriminator is probably the easiest
the discriminator gets an image right
here
it doesn't have to be generated it is a
either a generated image or
a real image and it needs to decide
you can see right here this means that
the input domain is a
vector or an image in this case and the
output is a number
it needs to decide if it's real or fake
now in fact it's not as easy because you
can see there are
these multiple heads right here so this
whole thing
as i said is built on this kind of
pseudo clustering approach there is this
pseudo label that comes out of the left
side
we're going to look at that um in a
second but
in essence you assume that there are
multiple
classes multiple domains in the data set
and the discriminator here has
one classification head for each of
those classes
so from somewhere outside it will get
the information
oh this is now supposed to be one of
those ginger cats
right as opposed to one of those black
and white cats or
one of the brown-haired cats um no it's
one of the ginger cats and then there is
a special
head on top of the classifier that only
classifies
fake from real ginger cats okay which is
a different classifier
from the other domains so the
discriminator
it's sort of a conditional discriminator
conditioned on a label
okay from the discriminator's point of
view it's simply
a label condition discriminator
discriminating between
real and false and i think that's
yeah how you train the discriminator is
you would give
an image and um
you would let this encoder here this
guiding network
label the image and how we come up with
this label again that we'll
look in a second but this just gives the
label and then
you'd still you for that particular
label you'd classify the image into real
or false
now the fact that there is this shared
part right here of course
is you could also think of having one
discriminator
per class but the shared part gives you
some shared features and so on but it's
not necessary it's not
the the point is that there is a
discriminator per
class it's class conditional
okay so what about
the generator i think is i guess is the
most complex
um what about this this uh encoding
network right here
it's e for encoder i guess but um they
also call it the guiding network
so what this does is this is what's
supposed to do
is it'll take an image any image
and it will output two things one is a
label
and one is a style code so the label
is supposed to be a number between
zero and da da da da da um k
minus one so that's supposed to be a
class label
and how do you know how many classes
there are if there are no labels you
just guess
and your best bet is to slightly over
guess
so if you expect there to be between 10
and 15 classes maybe put k to 20
okay you don't want to under guess but
you can over
guess but not by too much of course
so you have to have this um
this estimation of how many classes but
then
this e it simply comes up with a class
label
and it also comes up with the style code
now
these two things are going to go then
different pathways
in this in this network
the label is directly going to the
discriminator
right the generator does not see the
label
okay the style code
does not go to the discriminator but
goes to the generator
all right so the two inputs from the
encoder they one goes to the
discriminator which is the label
and one goes to the generator which is
the style
now the generator lastly it takes
a source image and it takes this style
code right here now the style code
is encapsulating as we said the style of
the reference
image so the style is supposed to be
whatever
whatever whatever makes
this domain of images the same so the
style the way we're going to train this
is
that the style is going to describe
somehow
all the images that are from these
labels the style is going to describe
whatever the style is it's very hard to
it's very hard to explain if we look at
the loss it becomes
clearer why the things are how they are
um so it takes the style code and it
takes the source
image and it combines them and its task
is to output this generated image as you
can see in this example the generated
image is basically this cat
but with the style of the reference
image
and it outputs an image and the
discriminator of course then
is tasked with differentiating whether
that image is
real or fake for the given label over
here
okay so this is the entire thing and you
all train this
jointly so you jointly train the encoder
to produce these class labels
and the styles you put you train the
generator to take in the styles and the
source images and output
the generated image to fool the
discriminator and the discriminator at
the same time
is trained to differentiate between real
and fake images based on the label that
the encoder
gives very very um
convoluted and complicated but there are
a few things that make it easier
first of all as you can see here the
pseudo label
is detached it's arc maxed and detached
so the pseudo-label really is a number
and there is no
gradient back propagation along this
line
okay that makes that makes it a lot
easier
so the so what we first need is we need
a way to train the encoder
to come up with suitable class labels
even though it doesn't get any back
propagation signal
into that part of its network so that's
where we start with the loss functions
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to take the following
approach we're going to take an image
and we're going to take a randomly
augmented version
so for example a random crop or a
horizontal flip and so on
so the now we bring in ideas from
self-supervision and again if you watch
the video on
learning to classify images without
labels this is one of their main
staples these self-supervised approaches
really tend to learn representations
that allow you
to self-cluster now in that paper they
go further and they do this nearest
neighbor thing
in this paper they just do sort of the
first step of this self-clustering
which i guess makes it such that you
could potentially improve this paper by
applying
the other paper but who knows
so we're going to take an image and we
we're going to
augment it okay so that means we're
going to like random crop it
or in change its luminance or
whatnot so we have two versions of the
same image
and what we want to maximize we want to
maximize the mutual information
between not between the images
themselves but
p is going to be this output of the
encoder so
x goes into the encoder and the encoder
outputs the style and the class label
the class label here so p is going to be
the class distribution
all right so this is going to be like a
histogram or maybe
the logits or the
yeah so it's going to be a histogram
over classes from which we're going to
sample
the label c or l or what not
y hat y but the p
is the distribution over output classes
so
since we don't have a label we can't
train the distribution like in a
supervised way
supervised way so what we'll have to say
is we want to maximize the mutual
information between the output
distribution of the image and the output
distribution of the augmented image
now that entails the following two
quantities there's the entropy
of p and there's the conditional entropy
of p given p augmented
now first of all it means we want to
maximize
this the entropy of p
and that's supposed to be over the
entire data set
so this is um the entropy over the
x what it means is that we want
different x's so if there's x1 x2
x3 and so on we want those to
have different distributions in labels
okay so if if the entropy
is really high of the distribution p
that means that different images get
assigned to different
classes some something like this all
right
if this is low then that would mean all
the images basically get assigned to the
same class
and that's not good we want our
classifier
if since we don't have labels it's a
it's basically a cluster
we want our cluster to sort of fill the
space of possible clusters
with the images so that's the first
thing we want to
maximize the mutual information we need
to maximize this entropy
and then second since this is a minus
here we need to minimize the conditional
entropy
of p given p augmented what does that
mean
that means if we know
the augmented version of an image its
class labeling
should be the same as the
unaugmented version so that means that
if i
now take one of these x's to x one
augmented of the into a plus augmented
right then that shouldn't really change
its class label
and this is what these so that
should sort of keep the class labeling
this is horrible
but the idea here is that it's kind of a
reverse thinking from supervised
learning
in supervised learning we have the label
like this is
class this is class five okay
this image is class five and our
thinking is this augmentation techniques
if i random crop an image or if i change
its
colorization a little bit the class is
not going to change right an airplane
with a
in front of a blue sky is still an
airplane in front of a bit bluer sky
so i assume that it'll still have the
same label
here i don't have the label but what i
can require
is to say whatever you output for the
image
it should be the same for the augmented
so these two objectives are enough to
give you sort of a rough
clustering of the output space maximize
the entropy
minimize the conditional entropy between
two versions of
the same image okay that's how we train
this pseudo labeling approach so now we
have a
we have a model that can give a label to
each image
very cool so how
do we train the
other parts now there are additional
additional losses here so
i'm not sure yeah we'll go over it
so this style part is also has to be
trained right this encoder
outputs a labeling we got that covered
and it outputs a style part
now the style part if you can see from
the graphic it actually goes
into let me erase some of that stuff
here
the style part actually is down here
and it feeds into the generator and
luckily they write detach here and since
they don't write detach anywhere here
that means that we do get gradient back
propagation
from the generator to the style code so
that means our our encoder here is
trained
to help the generator with its task
of fooling the discriminator okay
but um first of all we're going to
forget about that for now
what we're going to do is simply look at
a loss that they impose on the style
they wouldn't they don't have to impose
that loss but they have an additional
loss on the style codes
for the encoder in addition to the fact
that there is
gradient back propagating from g so the
second loss we're going to look at is
this style loss the stylus
is almost the same so the stylus loss is
a contrastive
loss so what you want to do is
if you have your data set you have your
data set of images
and you you know take images out and you
train your network on it you train then
take the next imagery you take batches
of image you take train
and so on like this right and now you
have this image
what you want to do for this to work is
you want to build up sort of a queue
of images that you have already looked
at like these images
these are going and the queue can be
let's say 10 long
and you would always throw out the
oldest and and and q and newest so when
you're done with this image right here
you'll put it into the queue
you load your next image and so on so
now what does this mean
you now always have a queue of other
images
and it's not important what they are as
long as they are others
right because now we're going to
compare ourselves with
others and this is this contrastive loss
right here
so this style loss is going to be a
contrastive loss between
this and this now the bottom part
this here these are the others these are
the
other images and whether the individual
quantities
so s is the style code of the image
you're considering
right now s plus you could have already
guessed it
is the style code of the augmented image
right so we had our image
x um let's go again with x1
x2 x3 are different images so we
put x1 through the encoder that gives us
s the style it also gives us the class
label but now we care about this head
that gives us the style code
and we augment x1 to be x1 plus
and we go we put that through the
encoder that gives us s plus and now
we also put
all of these other images remember these
are the images that we've looked at
previously
but the only real importance is that
there are other images
we put those through here and they get
the
s minus i in this case three
and two so now what we'll require
is that the s the style code of our
image
is closer to the style code of
its augmented version so the same
principle again
we want we'll say that you know these
augmentations they
don't really change anything about the
style now this argument is a bit more
wonky but if you think of you know
random crops and random flips
uh don't really change anything about
the fur color or so
of a of a cat so we want those two
to be closer together than
s is to any of these other images
okay so this is a contrast floss where
you pull together two things
that you think should be close and you
push apart
things that you think should be far away
from each other
so this style loss basically guarantees
that you have a distinct style for each
image that is robust to the
kind of transformations that you do
under augmentation
okay specifically this style loss
doesn't care about the domain right this
is for each image you don't know if
these
other images are from the same domain or
from different domains
and that's why the style is basically
individual
to the image but as we as we're going to
see
this style does capture something of the
domain
as well but this loss right here
is supposed to be each image has a style
right so this is the style code of x
this ampersand way classification
enables e to utilize not only the
similarity of the positive pair
but also the dissimilarity of the
negative pairs
where the negative style codes are
stored into a queue using previously
sampled images
we observe that adding this objective
significantly improves unsupervised
classification accuracy in animal phases
from this to that
compared to the previous over clustering
approach
okay so we have two outputs now
and now we go to the adversarial loss so
the question is how do we
train the generator and the
discriminator
so they have three different losses for
the generator and the discriminator and
the most important one of course is this
adversarial loss right here so the
discriminator simply tries to
distinguish
is an image real or fake
conditioned on a class
so in case of a real image and that's
this line right here
it tries to distinguish is this real or
fake
based on why and why is x
fed to the encoder and the encoder gives
you a label
all right that's and the label selects
the head of the discriminator
at the same time that the discriminator
is trying to distinguish real from fake
so these two lines the generator is
trying to fool the discriminator
so the upper if you've never seen a gan
loss
the upper part here that's the real data
and the bottom part here is the fake
data
now at the same time the discriminator
is trying to
um distinguish real from fake and the
generator is trying to
make the discrim fool the discriminator
so both are of
the generator and the discriminator are
actually using that loss
but the sign in front of it is different
okay
and since the generator is not involved
in the top line you can usually
leave that away because there's no back
prop path
through that and there's no back back
prop
path here because we detach the graph
right here so there's no gradient signal
going to
the encoder so this bottom line what
does it mean the generator will
take in an image and the style
now s tilde comes from x tilde it's
x tilde going through the encoder giving
you
s tilde so this is the reference image
right this is you want this this style
right here
this is the reference image and x is the
source image
so the generator is supposed to take the
and basically apply the style
from the reference image and generate uh
x i don't even know how to call this x
not tilde whatever x fake xf
and that's supposed to fool the
discriminator
now the question is which discriminator
right
uh because you need a label for the
discriminator the label is conditional
with this discriminator is pretty easy
because it's simply the label
of this image now however
as you can see the generator learns to
translate x to the target domain
while reflecting the style code s tilde
so y tilde is going to be the label
that comes out of this x so this
encoder right here is also going to give
us uh
y tilde and that's going to go here
all right so recap
what we want to put into the
discriminator is one time a
real image like we do up up here
and we get its label from the
encoder the encoder gets us a label for
each image
very cool we'll also take the same image
put it through the generator task the
generator with transferring the style of
another image
from here onto it we get the style from
the
encoder and then the generator
is supposed to make an image and we feed
that to the discriminator and the
discriminator discriminates
assuming it comes from class y tilde
now you see right here the generator
never has access
to y tilde okay so the generator is
kind of at a disadvantage here the
discriminator gets told
what kind of image it is in terms of
class
while the generator because it needs to
fool the discriminator
it needs to come up with an image of
that class but it has no idea of the
class it only has
the style code so it is forced
to learn to sort of
it is forced to learn to map a style
to associate a style with a particular
class and that's how you get the domain
into the style that's why the style can
capture
something like fur color of the
different cat breeds
because the generator is forced to take
the style that the encoder gives and
map it to an image of the class y
tilde also the encoder gives but doesn't
tell to the generator
okay and in fact there is a more path
because you now back propagate the loss
to the encoder
which means that the encoder will even
help the generator
it will help the generator
make style codes that are very class
specific
now you can maybe think why why wouldn't
you just have one
output why doesn't the encoder simply
output the label also as the
style because that would be the easiest
and the reason is because we have
different
losses on the style and the
label
okay otherwise that would be a valid
tactic
so that's cool that's the adversary loss
that's the most important loss
now there's also additional losses
so they they do additional losses that
they add on top
for the generator they say in order to
prevent
degenerate situation where the generator
ignores the style code
and synthesizes a random image in the
domain y
or in the domain y tilde we impose a
style contrastive loss to the generator
so now there's still the danger that the
the generator simply produces a valid
image
right from the data set or even from the
domain white tilde
though i don't know how it would know
why tilde or i've just not seen
something
i in my mind it doesn't get the y tilde
but it could read it from the style
but here the danger is to ignore the
style i'm slightly
i'm slightly confused by this part but
maybe looking at the loss we'll
we'll clear it out so they say we impose
a style contrast of loss to the
generator
now this is almost the same as we
imposed on
the encoder so the generator you can see
there is a
contrastive loss again where you want to
be you want these things to be close
and you want these things to be far
apart so
these s minuses these are going to be
the ones from your the style
codes of the images from your queue so
these are just going to be
other images here
estilde that's going to be the style
that you get
from your reference image so your
reference image is going through the
encoder and that's going to give you
this right here now the question is what
is s
prime here because in the before we
simply had
s which was our source image
our source image style now what is s
prime here s prime is going to be
it gets more complicated yes s prime is
going to be
whoops is going to be the round trip
to the encoder so
it's going to be if i generate my image
from the source image x and the
style s tilde of the reference
and then i ask my generate my
encoder again what style does this have
i get the s prime so it's kind of a
round trip right
so i i take
i take this i'd ask the encoder what
style is it
that's s tilde right then i take
s tilde go to the generator together
with a source image x and that gives me
like
x fake and then i ask my generator again
what style would you assign to the fake
image i just produced
and then the encoder will tell you i'll
give it
s fake or s prime in this case
and then i compare that s
prime with the one i gave before
okay so it's sort of a round trip loss
of my reference image right
so what does that do if i now and then i
ask that s
prime be close to s tilde so that means
if i generate an image
with the style of my reference image the
outcoming image
should better have the style of the
reference image
that's all it says so the style of the
thing i
generate given this style
they should better be close and
especially closer together than the
style
with any other image in my queue it
makes sense but it's kind of convoluted
so you go with your out it's kind of a
reconstruction loss
except in style space
all right and then the last thing is an
actual
image reconstruction loss so
what you'll do is your generator will
produce
x sorry will produce an image from the
source image
and its own style right here that's
important
uh before we input s tilde here
so this now is we input
the source image and its own style so we
go with
x we go to the e and we
put the style here and we tell
the generator if i input the source
image and
its own style then what you give me back
better be
the source image itself right this is a
consistency loss
that tells the generator that basically
it learns now the generator learns to
the generality learns to map to
recognize
an image with its own style sort of
because it doesn't know
right it doesn't know that what's coming
in here is the
style of um it of the image x
but now you teach it and i think before
this loss you'd have a good
chance that uh the styles would just be
all over the place they would sort of be
consistent but they will not be
aligned and with this you force that
the style of an image itself if you gen
if you put that into the generator it
will
lead to that image itself
okay that's it so this is ah
this is extremely convoluted right the
discriminator is the easiest the
discriminator is a class conditional
discriminator
that gets the label from some mechanism
that decides on a label right okay
that's the easiest the encoder
has two parts the pseudo label which is
over here
which is trained completely unsupervised
detached from everything else in a self
self-clustering
approach while the
style part here is trained first of all
in a contrastive way
which makes sense and also
in a back propagated way from the
generator so the style generation
mechanism tries to help the generator
okay and that means it's going to leak
some information about the label
into the style because that helps the
generator the generator needs to
if the generator knows what sort of
class it's going to produce
it's going to be better okay so you can
count on that information being in there
but also
also because of all the other losses
that the generator has
and the contrastive loss on the style
this style code is going to sort of
describe
the individual style of an image
and but it's also going to describe what
the style of that class is because it
technically needs to contain information
about the class
and that's why i think this
works with this style because there is
no inherent notion of like
this is this is a this is the pose of a
cat
or something like this yeah it still
seems like a bit magic to me
and then the generator is first of all
trained to fool the discriminator
given an image a source image and a
style
and you can fool the discriminator by
producing an image that's
so good it looks real and
specifically it looks real in the class
that the pseudo label has given right so
in the class that the encoder has given
to it
so the generator must somehow come up
with an image that's of that
class and so it will
it will be forced to interpret the style
code in terms of that class label
which makes the style code the style
code
and also we have these two additional
losses
which is the round trip loss to the
style space
so whatever the generator outputs
you should be able to recover the style
um
from it by putting it through the
encoder again and then lastly there is a
consistency loss where you say if i
only put an image into a source image
and i input
its own style again going through the
encoder
you should give me back the source image
itself
very complex and all of the generator
loss is back propagated
through to the encoder so this is the
full loss
as i said discriminator easy adversarial
loss
generator adversarial loss plus this
style round trip consistency plus the
own image round trip consistency
encoder gets all of the generator loss
all of it so all of this goes
here so the encoder fully helps the
generator
and it is also trained with this mutual
information
and the style contrastive loss
wow that's some losses wow that that's a
lot of damage
um so they do different investigations
into their model here and i don't even
know if we've missed some of the
pictures but ultimately what you can now
do is you can do image to image
translation either
that's the cool thing you can have a
reference image for one
or what you can do is you can ask your
discriminator what kind of
domains are there sorry you can ask your
encoder
what kind of domains are there you've
guessed the number of domains so it's
maybe
10 or in this case it's uh eight
eight dom eight domains of cats
and you can simply divide your data set
into these eight domains right one two
three four five and so on
no this is ten okay i can't see anymore
so ten domains and then you can simply
calculate
for each image you calculate the style
vector so the style
the style and then you simply take
the average one over the number in that
in that domain you take the average
style vector
and that's going to be your target style
so you can do image to
image translation with a reference image
or you can do image to image translation
for an entire group of images for
example
all the images in a given domain and
that's how they do
these graphs right here now just quickly
wait until my tablet decides to
show me the paper again thank you all
right
they do a bunch of investigations into
their
holy unholy mixture of losses especially
the first concern is
couldn't we just train the guiding
network
like by its own on its own and then
after that train this gan thing right
that's what we had at the very beginning
we said
there's this guiding network and it does
the clustering and all
and couldn't we just train this gan
architecture on top
of the frozen guiding network and
their conclusion is no if we train
everything together
it works better so on the left you have
whenever you train the guiding network
by itself
and what you're seeing here is the t-sne
visualization t-sne is a
a down like a non-linear visualization
tool
of style codes extracted by our guiding
network
the ground truth domains of all test
images
is represented in different colors so
this is a data set
that has labels but you don't you don't
provide the labels to this algorithm the
algorithm is completely unlabeled
but for purposes of investigating we'll
visualize the labels with colors
and what you'll see here are the the
t-sne visualizations of the style codes
so things that are close together they
have similar
style codes and the ideal case would be
if
things that are close together
here have the same label and that means
the style
is sort of representative of the domain
okay that's what we want we want the
style to capture
the domain of an image and ideally not
the image itself too much
now on the left you see that there is
quite a bit of overlap between these
quite a bit of wash
between the style and the group and on
the right if you jointly train
the gan together with the guiding
network you see
that these classes of the style codes
which have no reason to cluster are much
more clustered and separated
and they are separated much more along
the lines of
the ground truth classes okay so that's
pretty cool now i would actually be
interested in what happens if you do the
separate training with the full
pipeline of this uh learning to classify
images without labels thing
and their nearest neighbor thing because
they've also shown that just
purely this self clustering doesn't
work too well but if you then do the
nearest neighbor thing on top then that
improves the classification
significantly
so this could potentially help
either the separate or the joint
training right here
and there might be a connection between
the joint training and whatever
they're doing in any case
they also show that then these fid which
is a quality metric
for gans lower is better that the joint
training
goes way lower in the fid than the
separate
training okay that's that's the reason
why they built this convoluted thing
because it works way better and here
they ablate they ablate some of the
losses
to investigate what's really going on
and in this case
disney visualization of the star space
of our guiding network
trained on this since this does not have
ground truth domain labels
each data point is colored with the
guiding network's prediction
so each color is whatever the guiding
network says the class
is and the dot is one
style each dot is one style vector and
they're
projected down to two dimensions you can
see pretty clearly
that um the individual classes
the individual clusters of style vectors
correspond to different labels
of the guiding network which is to be
expected
but also since they overestimate the
number of classes in this case
uh you can see that the even though
the class label is different the style
network will group the very similar
classes together you can see here these
are both
cheetahs and here are both lions so
it'll group them together
which is pretty cool and sort of
verifies that it
recognizes these these different things
because you force the guiding network to
make 10 classes but the style
network is simply continuous so it's
cool to see that the style network
will make one cluster with styles
even though it's different labels and
here you can see different samples from
these domains just to verify
that the guiding network has actually
learned to separate
things i i still find this pretty um
pretty magical to this is completely
unsupervised and it sort of
finds these uh clusters by itself
all right they have a bunch of images
here as i said this is no longer
with one reference images image this is
where you take the entire domain so you
self-label with your guiding network
and then you take the mean vector and
that's going to be your target style
vector and these are the source images
that you transfer and you can see that
you know works pretty well so they
always have like one
adult animal and one child animal
i guess not or just two different ones
here this is particularly cute though
i have to show you this fox right here
what's going on with that fox like
someone help that fox
yeah um so we're not at perfection yet
as you can see
but it's you know that that looks like a
pretty
pretty cool photo maybe
okay where did it go maybe it slipped
maybe it's an it's an offshoot of this
one on the top left
yeah who knows these data sets they have
their way and um
so this is sort of where you can see the
limitations right here
um that's not how a baby snow leopard
looks
you see the limitations here in that all
of these
animal faces they're still pretty
aligned like they're
fairly frontal not exactly but they're
fairly
frontal pictures um they're fairly
standardized and so on
so i don't think we're yet at the level
where we can just do you know um
fully image to image and you see it
especially with faces because we
as us humans are extremely good at
you know seeing when there's something
wrong with a face um but it's
still it's still pretty impressive
what's possible
and i think if the past is of any
indication
here is summer to winter that actually
looks good
if the past is of any indication then
this technology will be pushed pretty
hard and
soon we'll be able to do this with a
simple smartphone app or something like
this
so i invite you to check out the paper
right here they have
lots and lots and lots of examples and
t-sniff plots and whatnot
in their appendix they have the code
online as far as i
as i have seen and with that
let me know what you think in the
comments bye bye